pour vie réellement dans une ville et un
quartier fantôme depuis quatre jours ici
à kiev et c'est de plus en plus je vous
le dis plus en plus saisissant de plus
en plus frappante les habitants qui
restent se terre dans leur abri personne
ne se risque à sortir à part quelques
voitures et ceux que l'on croise
évidemment eh bien ce sont ces cortèges
incessant de deux militaires ou de ses
membres de la société civile qui sont
engagés dans la défense territoriale des
hommes en civil armés qui montent la
garde et qui prépare cette défense donc
le couvre feu a été levé il y à une
heure un couvre-feu qui est établie par
la loi martiale dans tout le pays qui
est ici extrêmement mis en oeuvre un
couvre feu de 20h à 7h extrêmement
strictes et au moment où je vous parle
on entende à 20 km au nord est bien des
explosions des bombardements cela aussi
incessantes c'est la ville d'hier pin au
nord-ouest où les combats font rage et
se sont intensifiées depuis hier je ne
sais pas si vous avez pu entendre à
bombardements ça n'arrête pas et c'est
cette ville stratégique extrêmement
importante qui est à 20 km au nord ouest
où le rouleau compresseur de cette
offensive rusé bien se déploie très
franchement la question qui se pose
aujourd'hui pour tous les habitants de
kiev c'est rester ou partir de fuir
cette capitale dont on sait qu'elle va
être un moment ou un autre totalement
assiégés qu'elle sera sans doute pas
aimé remet éthiquement puisqu'il y a
énormément de route qui rentrent et
sortent mais en tout cas il y aura cette
présence russe très importante on sait
ici que c'est la stratégie de vladimir
poutine donc les habitants des quartiers
centraux que se taire je le disais dans
les abris mais c'est vraiment la
question que se pose tout le monde
aujourd'hui ce que je tiendrais ce que
je reste pour la plupart des familles ce
sont des scènes déchirantes puisqu'il
s'agit en général les pères de famille
doivent rester je rappelle qu'il s'agit
aussi d'un ordre du gouvernement
ukrainien tous les hommes âgés entre 20
et 60 ans ne peuvent pas quitter le pays
doivent se mobiliser pour la défense
nationale et bien les familles et bien
s'entredéchirent puisque les enfants et
les femmes souvent sont envoyés en
pologne ou dans d'autres endroits du
pays et ceux qui restent sont les hommes
qui doivent prendre les armes et ils
sont beaucoup donc c'est vraiment toute
une vie rennes se mobilisent et se
préparer à défendre coûte que coûte ses
défenses